Speaker 1: Let me briefly mention to you that
Donald Trump exploded yesterday and today
on Truth Social as a second Trump arrest is
now looming and the Fox News Dominion trial
is set to start.
It was set to start today.
It got pushed to tomorrow.
But even that, there's speculation that maybe
Fox News is going to settle.
And Fox News is sort of stuck between a rock
and a hard place here, because on the one
hand, if Fox News settles the Dominion lawsuit,
even if they are not literally admitting fault,
they're admitting fault.
You're settling it.
If you were if you actually were right here,
if you didn't do the things you're accused
of, if you were right to air the things you
aired, and if Trump really did win 2020, then
why are you settling?
If they don't settle, they risk an even bigger,
bigger loss.
Weeks of humiliating headlines.
And it's I don't envy the position Fox News
is in.
It's, of course, their fault that they're
in this position to begin with.
Trump's idea which he posted to truth social
is.
Fox News should just insist that Trump really
did win in 2020, wrote.
Speaker 5: Essential.
Speaker 1: Trump posting to Troth this morning
in all capital letters.
If Fox would finally admit that there was
large scale cheating and irregularities in
the 2020 presidential election, which would
be a good thing for them and for America,
the case against them, which should not have
existed at all, would be greatly weakened.
Back up.
Those patriots at Fox instead of throwing
them under the bus.
And they are right.
There is so much proof like mass ballot stuffing
caught on government cameras, FBI colluding
with Twitter and Facebook, state legislatures
not used, etc.
Now Trump isn't wrong.
Well, let me.
How do I even say this?
A defense to defamation is that the things
you said are true?
That is accurate.
You can defend yourself against defamation
by saying it can't be defamation because I
stated truth or truth, depending on your preference.
Of course, the idea that Fox News would try
to get itself out of this by going and making
a case that Trump actually won the 2020 election
would be so humiliating and laughable that
it could potentially be the worst possible
outcome for Fox News of all of it.
But that's Donald Trump's legal advice.
Take it for what it's worth.
And then yesterday, Trump petro thing also
in all capital letters.
Quote, So the Democrats are allowed to cheat
on and rig and he spells rig with two G's,
which is interesting.
Democrats are allowed to cheat on and rig
a presidential election and they want to indict
Republicans for a campaign violation.
This is classic.
So the totality of this is Trump has been
arrested and indicted.
He thinks it's politically motivated.
He thinks it's bogus.
He thinks even if he did the thing he's accused
of, it's very minor compared to the theft
of an election that he actually won.
And his legal advice to Fox on this issue
is settle.
Don't settle.
Fight it by arguing that I really won, which
is maybe the craziest legal advice that I've
ever heard.
I hope Fox does not settle the lawsuit, and
I hope that we get six weeks potentially of
embarrassing, humiliating and insane headlines
related to that trial, which, by the way,
will have the sort of side benefit of being
endlessly triggering to the failed former
president.